amazon's sixth annual prime day is all
set to kick off tomorrow amid a pandemic
that has dramatically changed our
shopping habits
more than 150 million americans
subscribe to amazon's prime for 48 hours
starting overnight at 3 o'clock eastern
time midnight pacific
they'll be able to shop for discounted
electronic goods home goods
fashion toys and more dan ackerman is
senior managing editor with our partners
at cnet
he joins us with how prime day is
different this year dan good morning
good to see you now this feels so
awkward to me dan we just did a story
about with nancy cordes where people are
literally trying to figure out where i'm
going to get my next meal
my next paycheck then we go to amazon
prime where people can get discounts on
foods fashion goods all of that good
stuff too
so it's like we're dealing with two
realities here but it is different this
year
even for amazon prime
it's very different for amazon prime
because we're used to this amazon
invented holiday that somehow become a
thing happening
over the summer and then later on you
come back in the fall and then it's like
holiday season and black friday and
everything
well for a variety of reasons including
you know the difficulty had shipping
products and receiving
products amazon moved it to later in the
year they finally said
oh okay mid-october so what you really
have now is
this holiday season sort of kicks off
with this now and then runs through
black friday and the rest of the holiday
season is just sort of one big you know
giant two and a half month sale season
uh which may burn people out frankly so
a lot of kids are learning remotely
these days so i would think that you're
looking at computers laptops those kind
of things for deals
you know that's one of the most popular
you know categories over the last
several months especially because
every kid is remote learning needs their
own device now and everybody's working
from home so they all need their own
device you can't have a shared family
computer anymore really
so whenever you see a 500 decent laptop
or a good tablet go on sale somewhere
they sell out very quickly
so i think on prime day starting
tomorrow you will see a big emphasis on
these lower cost laptops on chromebooks
which are great for students
you know and hopefully they'll be able
to keep them in stock because previously
when they've been some good deals you
know you have to run in and snatch them
up pretty quickly
kitchen and home goods too
that's always really popular on prime
day in previous years
and especially as now it's part of the
holiday shopping season and people are
also
you know staying home and doing more
things at home i would definitely expect
interest in in things like instant pots
and the kitchenaid mixers
or even uh you know like those little
ninja blenders uh you know things that
run from less expensive to fancier and
more expensive and maybe it's a holiday
gift
for yourself or someone else and
realistically dan how much shopping are
people doing i'm still struck by nancy's
report reminds me of the day when my dad
died i was very upset i looked at the
car next to me the kids there
singing and laughing and joking and
somebody said to me the day you're
having your worst day
somebody's having their best day and
both are true
how much shopping are people really
doing these days
i mean that really is the question that
this holiday season is going to answer
are people going to hold back uh because
they're concerned about finances because
they don't have a job
because they're worried about having a
job in the future um
or are people gonna say well this is the
time when things are usually on sale so
i'll stock up for things now or maybe
they'll say
i'll just get the minimum number you
know amount of things that i think i
need to get to cover the holiday season
now
or i'll wait for black friday yeah
amazon's been a big help for a lot of
people and dan
i see you've embraced the david
letterman look so
go fully i'm all in now that's right
we'll be right back